[Applauso]
buonasera
allora cominciamo con quelle che saranno
le mie parole stasera cambiamento
resilienza mentoring and networking
capiamo il perché nel mio percorso
professionale e personale ho incontrato
molte persone uomini e donne che
rivestono ruoli apicali strategici in
contesti molto diversi
spesso mi sono interrogata per cercare
di capire se ci fosse qualche elemento
qualche comune denominatore che
collegava tutte queste persone e devo
dire che una chiave di lettura l'ho
trovata quella del cambiamento e spesso
anche in una situazione di difficoltà
ho provato un po a rivolgere la stessa
domanda a me stessa ho riguardato il mio
percorso degli ultimi dieci anni dove
sicuramente ho fatto tante cose che non
mi sarei aspettata e una sicuramente
anche quella di essere su questo palco
stasera è anche nel mio caso il
principale driver è stato un momento di
discontinuità un momento in cui ho
dovuto ricorrere a tutte le mie risorse
interne e non solo in particolare quelle
esterne che avevo sempre tenuto poco in
considerazione un vero e proprio appello
alla resilienza ma cominciamo
dall'inizio
che cosa faccio io sono un manager che
da oltre 25 anni lavora prevalentemente
nel mondo dei servizi finanziari in
realtà italiane ma anche internazionali
ho abitato in cinque città per periodi
abbastanza lunghi sia in italia che
negli stati uniti ma sono anche come
dicevamo all'inizio una business angel
sono socia di italian angels for growth
sono la fondatrice di un'associazione no
profit
perché sostiene lo sviluppo
professionale delle donne p dabliu and
rom e sono anche consigliera e in alcuni
cd ha evidentemente tanti ruoli che
possono essere anche percepiti come come
diversi quindi di fatto diciamo la la
domanda si pone no su come questo possa
essere successo questo di fatto è
successo dieci anni fa
dieci anni fa cambio nuovamente città
cambio lavoro mi trovo diciamo dopo
dieci anni che sono state all'interno di
una realtà multinazionale che mi ha
avvolto e per certi aspetti anche
isolato a dovermi confrontare con una
realtà molto diversa
io ero abituata come dire a raggiungere
risultati molto concentrata su me stessa
le mie competenze e la mia capacità la
mia la mia passione però la nuova realtà
in realtà mi ha fatto scoprire subito
che questo non era più non era più
sufficiente
ed è qui che io di fatto riscopro quelli
che saranno poi negli anni successivi i
miei due alleati
da una parte il mentoring che già
nell'esperienza americana
avevo vissuto ma che avevo trovato
sempre molto sterile e il networking che
in realtà avevo sempre evitato perché
l'avevo trovato faticoso e questo in
realtà sono diventati veramente degli
asset importanti
partiamo dal mentoring mentore è
l'educatore di telemaco quando ulisse
parte per la guerra e di fatto no la
figura del mentore è quella di guida e
la persona di esperienza che affianca la
persona che sta iniziando e che in un
rapporto paritario fornisce consigli
fornisce suggerimenti di fatto è un
punto di riferimento
tendenzialmente noi per siamo per la
persona più giovane
in realtà negli ulti
primi anni stiamo riscontrando grande
importanza anche a quello che si chiama
il reverse mentoring in realtà in questo
caso mentor diventano i ragazzi più
giovani i ragazzi che nascono col
digitale e che diventano loro dei punti
di riferimento per persone che magari
lavorativamente nel concetto più
tradizionale sono già affermate ma che
sono più lontane da quelli che sono i
nuovi i nuovi strumenti o amleto ci
insegna dicendo noi sappiamo chi siamo
ma non sappiamo cosa potremmo essere
ecco per me è successo così in questa
nuova realtà italiana in cui lavoravo
dopo un primo momento dove le cose
funzionavano bene c'è un momento di
cambiamento un momento di difficoltà non
so se per caso ho pensato ma sicuramente
molto utile
l'azienda mi affianca un mentor e questo
è un momento per me di grande
cambiamento perché in questo rapporto
che si è sviluppato con mentore io
acquisisco dei fondamentali che poi
applicherò in continuità per il resto
diciamo delle mie esperienze e che
ancora oggi proprio per il risultato
positivo che hanno avuto su di me io
nell'ambito dell'associazione che
sostiene lo sviluppo professionale delle
donne
cerco di trasferire per me è di fatto i
principi sono stati tre quello di non
perdere di vista la prospettiva di lungo
periodo
e inutile fare le battaglie per
l'immediato quando la partita più
importante invece è più avanti nel tempo
ascoltare molto e parlare il giusto non
c'è bisogno sempre di puntualizzare di
voler poter dire l'ultima parola e
soprattutto avere il coraggio di
chiedere ecco per me il coraggio di
chiedere è stata una svolta
io oggi ho potuto avere l'esperienza di
sedere in alcuni consigli di
amministrazione molto diversi perchè
parliamo di una società di internet
quotata parliamo di una banca parliamo
di un accademia di belle arti perché ho
chiesto ho smesso di aspettare
che qualcuno riconoscendo le mie
capacità
mi chiamasse a fare delle cose a cui ero
interessata e le persone a cui mi sono
rivolta in realtà con grande timore sono
state molto trasparenti han detto e
fatto bene a dirmelo perché se tu nun me
l'avessi detto non avrei mai pensato che
questa potesse essere una cosa che ti
interessava quindi di fatto no il
mentoring per me è stato veramente
importante passiamo adesso invece al
tema del networking
allora il sempre diciamo serio della mia
esperienza americana dove io ho lavorato
sia in italia che all'estero
ho sempre dedicato poca attenzione a
sviluppare relazioni durature solide con
le persone erano sempre diciamo relativa
al momento specifico alla situazione che
stavamo vivendo in quel momento io di
fatto amo definire i primi 20 anni della
mia esperienza all'università e
lavorativa come i 20 anni in cui ho un
buco relazionale
ho conosciuto molte persone ho trascorso
anche dei periodi lunghi insieme ma di
fatto non ho costruito un legame è un
rapporto che ho costruito diciamo nel
tempo e di fatto oggi tante di queste
persone hanno fatte esperienze
interessanti rivestono ruoli importanti
ma di fatto io non sono più in contatto
con con loro è in realtà io credo molto
al concetto americano che your network
is your network ma nel senso positivo
del termine poi soprattutto noi donne
tendiamo sempre ad associare al concetto
di networking di lobby una connotazione
negativa ecco secondo me questo è un
altro passaggio culturale importante di
riconoscere il valore del network perché
proprio grazie al network che io di
fatto sono arrivata insieme ad altre
undici donne affondare p da blue and ed
avere la possibilità anche di dare un
feedback a tante donne
compì dabliu en noi ci siamo soprattutto
concentrate su un programma di mentoring
no proprio per l'esperienza anche
positiva che io avevo detto dal 2003 di
cui io vi ho parlato dal 2013 quando
abbiamo fondato l'associazione abbiamo
lanciato quattro programmi di mentoring
il quinto parte adesso il 17 di aprile e
in questo programmino coinvolto 360
mentor e menti in particolare 160
mentore e 220 fra i mentor abbiamo anche
una presenza di cui insomma di uomini di
cui noi siamo soddisfatti perché sono
una quarantina perché crediamo sia molto
importante questo questo scambio una
nuova esperienza che abbiamo fatto
nell'ultimo anno cioè lo scorso e di
mettere insieme mentoring and networking
in quella che un attività di gruppo e
mentoring cioè abbiamo individuato delle
tematiche che pensavamo potessero essere
di interesse per le nostre socie
personal branding story telling digital
e in questo caso con un mentor di fatto
un gruppo di sette dieci donne si
incontra ogni mese per discutere insieme
per confrontarsi su queste tematiche il
networking di fatto è molto importante
anche nella mia attività di business
angelo questo perché perché di fatto è
attraverso il networking che si possono
individuare nuove start up di interesse
è anche un modo per aiutare le start up
a loro volta a trovare dei finanziatori
ma è soprattutto il rapporto tra il
mentor e lo start upper nella
definizione del business model
nell'affidamento del business plan
ma soprattutto nella costituzione del
team e garantire il giusto mix fra e
risorse che può essere l'elemento
determinante per il successo o meno
della startup così per me è successo con
red hook credo che la prima start up in
cui ho investito è una piattaforma
digitale
che ha l'obiettivo di insegnare la
matematica ai ragazzi che vanno dalle
elementari fino alle superiori in
maniera innovativa e che diciamo si
caratterizza per poter diventare
l'alternativa no al libro al libro
cartaceo come sono arrivata a renault
che sono arrivata red hook attraverso il
mio network per che partecipavo ad un
corso di formazione per donne per
l'ingresso nel cda è un corso che
nell'arco di cinque anni ha formato 250
donne chiara che è la founder della
startup faceva parte di questo gruppo ci
siamo prima conosciuta a distanza
attraverso i social poi attraverso
amicizie comuni ci siamo incontrate
l'eni ha raccontato del suo progetto e
io ho partecipato in maniera entusiasta
la cosa interessante che poi una volta
che siamo arrivati al dunque al momento
dell'investimento è emerso in maniera
chiara che altri soci che stavano
investendo nella start ato facevano
parte di altri network che io avevano e
questo conferma il fatto che your
network easy york network
in realtà il vero tema qual è il vero
tema è che se guardiamo anche al tema
femminile no che a me molto caro
parlavamo di pi dabliu and rom in italia
il gender gap come in tanti altri paesi
è molto è molto elevato il 27 per cento
solo il 27 per cento delle donne e
riversano ruoli manageriali signor la
cosa secondo me è più significativa è
che il 70 per cento degli italiani non
crede nelle capacità scientifiche delle
donne
il 61 del 5 per cento delle donne
ricevono una paga o non adeguata o pari
a zero per il lavoro che svolgono
rispetto a un 22 per cento degli uomini
e se guardiamo la posizione nel ranking
per gender gap del world economic forum
noi siamo crollati all'ottantaduesimo
posto qual è il fattore il fattore è
che l'esclusione dai network la mancanza
di role model e la mancanza di mentor
secondo me sono sicuramente alcuni dei
fattori che ci portano a questo tipo di
risultato e quindi è fondamentale che
anche le donne come dire si aprano al
tema del networking e cerchino dei
mentori uomini o donne che li aiutino a
poter crescere professionalmente e
personalmente mi piace chiudere con
questa frase di robert che trovo molto
come dire è vicina anche al messaggino
del mondo a due velocità vivere senza
capitale sociale non è facile che si
tratti di un ambiente di un paesino
dell'italia meridionale di un povero in
una metropoli americana o di un
facoltoso imprenditore di un distretto
industriale ad alta tecnologia
io aggiungo solo per chiudere che io
credo fortemente che mentoring and
networking possano essere le porte di
accesso per una dimensione globale di
crescita di condivisione e di scambio
grazie mille